Qué significa para el futuro de la
industria de la música la sesión de
Shakira y bizarrap
Buenas noches Andrés y gracias a ustedes
por la invitación esto sin duda es el
fenómeno cultural latino para abrir el
año las cifras todavía son más grandes
de la ontavas tenemos 67 millones de
virus en YouTube en Spotify tanto en
instagram vamos a superar los 30
millones y todos los implicados incluso
las marcas fueron trending topic en
varios países a la vez se han creado más
de cuatrocientos mil tiktoks con el
audio y estoy en tan solo un plazo de
dos días esto es uno de los
acontecimientos digitales más
importantes del entretenimiento en
español súper beneficioso para todos los
Implicados En el que cualquier marca si
quiere vincular esto se da por un
fenómeno de Community management que
responde ante el cruce de fenómenos
culturales que le llegan a distintas
audiencias por un lado bizarrap por otro
lado del Shakira y por el otro lado
Piqué Por qué fue tan exitoso porque se
llegó a jugar con las audiencias de los
tres que son audiencias que usualmente
no interactúan No es igual la persona
que siga Piqué que la que sigue a
bizarrap que la Mira Estos tipos de
personalidades generan pasiones muy
intensas en sus audiencias lo que llevó
a que hubiera muchos memes polémica
comentarios muy intensos y que la gente
quisiera tomar partido de esta situación
esto respondiendo tu pregunta Abre una
puerta para que estas colaboraciones
cada vez más inesperadas entre fenómenos
culturales de distintas audiencias se
den más a menudo ya el año pasado
habíamos visto algunos acercamientos
similares por ejemplo entre el Kun
Agüero y los streamers españoles Pero
con esto creo que los números hablan por
sí solos para dar cuenta de un fenómeno
sin precedentes que supera incluso a
despacito al ser la canción con más
vistas en 24 horas a juzgar por lo que
usted dice Entonces se trata de una
estrategia de Shakira para tener un
alcance en el mercado de las nuevas
generaciones no
no creo que sea únicamente una
estrategia de Shakira creo que todos los
beneficia todos los implicados Perdón en
esta situación incluyendo las marcas
están viendo beneficiadas porque como
pudimos ver Piqué también Tuvo una
reacción asociando a Casio que bueno
Casio no se caracteriza por ser una
cuenta con un alto movimiento a nivel
digital y de comunidad de hecho su
cuenta oficial en Twitter no publicaba
nada desde el 2015 sin embargo después
de esto y el patrocinio a la kingsley y
la gran cantidad de cuentas falsas que
usan su nombre para aprovechar el
momento la marca va a estar como nunca
más relevante en una plataforma que
nunca había utilizado significativamente
esto no solo fue beneficioso para
Shakira o para bizarrap también lo fue
para Piqué para las marcas mencionadas
en la canción Y fue tal su éxito que
marcas que no tienen nada que ver están
tratando de montarse en esta situación
porque ya no es algo que beneficie
únicamente
cultural la canción pasó de ser un
sencillo a volverse un fenómeno digital
en el que quieren estar implicados
muchos más de los netamente presentes
ahora no hubo publicidad para la canción
Sin embargo este impacto a que se debe
yo creo que parte Eso es parte de la
estrategia él se ha encargado a lo largo
de los últimos años de generar un
branding un reconocimiento de marca
alrededor de sucesiones en las que ni
siquiera sale por ejemplo los viernes
que son el día favorito de la mayoría de
artistas para salir justamente porque
sabe que lo suyo va a ser una Primicia
ya el trabajo de posicionamiento de
marca que tenía que hacer lo hizo varios
años atrás todo el mundo está esperando
la sorpresa de cuál va a ser el
siguiente artista en las sesiones
bizarrap y pues Apenas salió Shakira
solo bastó que los hubiera un día antes
para tener este efecto de expectativa
que una vez se mezcló con Piqué pues
reventó internet